[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
we have been failed simone biles and
fellow olympians call out the fbi for
botching the larry nassar investigation
it was like serving innocent children up
to a pedophile on a silver platter plus
a shocking revelation months after a
double homicide so he arranged to have
this guy shoot him how a prominent south
carolina attorney ended up in a murder
for higher scheme and a father's murder
sentence revealed after the brutal
killing of a boy with autism how long
joseph daniels will be put away in the
death of baby joan plus a monumental
conviction overturned what a minnesota
supreme court ruling could mean for
ex-officer derek shovin law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin we begin with a scathing hearing
on the fbi's handling of the larry
nassar investigation and the incredible
testimony from the young women he's
accused of abusing olympic athletes are
now calling out the agency for failing
to act
former usa gymnastic team doctor larry
nassar is now serving 175 years sentence
for sexually assaulting young athletes
those young women say they reported the
abuse to the fbi more than a year before
agents acted according to a federal
investigation indianapolis field office
special agent jay abbott and another
agent neglected to interview accusers
limited follow-up and lie to officials
to minimize errors abbott reportedly
even tried to get a job with a u.s
olympic committee in that time between
july 2015 and september 2016 the
investigator general's office believes
nassar abused 70 athletes in total
officials believe nassar abused more
than 300 athletes before he was brought
to justice in 2016. simone biles and her
fellow olympians testified before the
senate judiciary committee on wednesday
calling out the fbi for botching their
investigation
we suffered and continued to suffer
because no one at fbi usag or the usopc
did what was necessary to protect us
we have been failed and we deserve
answers to be clear i blame larry nassar
and i also blame
an entire system
that enabled and
perpetrated his abuse
usa gymnastics in con in concert with
the fbi and the olympic committee were
working together to conceal that larry
nassar was a predator
i then proceeded to tell them about
london
and how he'd signed me up last on his
sheet so he could molest me for hours
twice a day i told him i told them how
he molested me
right before i won my team gold medal
this was very clear cookie cutter
pedophilia and abuse and this is
important because i told the fbi all of
this and they chose to falsify my report
and to not only minimize my abuse but
silence me yet again
nassar found more than 100 new victims
to molest
it was like serving innocent children up
to a pedophile
on a silver platter why would duly sworn
federal law enforcement officers ignore
reports of abuse by a doctor across
state lines and country borders for a
future job opportunity or were there
additional incentives and pressures
special agent abbott retired several
years ago and the fbi only fired the
other agent michael langman two weeks
ago several u.s senators are now calling
for a prosecution of those fbi agents
if i were in your shoes
i would be walking across the street
to the attorney general of the united
states
and i would be saying
you
need to prosecute
why aren't you doing that
well i i don't want to get into my
discussions with the attorney general uh
i have a lot of respect for him and for
the the privacy of our conversations
i will say
that in this particular instance
the case agents
responsible for the investigation as is
appropriate
were the inspector general's office's
agents
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney mike corobonix and terry austin
mike the issues these women are
testifying to seem systematic both in
the u.s olympic committee and in the fbi
if we do see charges against fbi agents
what do you think those could be
well there are federal charges that
could be filed as one of the young women
testified to
she made
reports and reported to fbi agents who
falsified reports falsification of
reports is a violation of federal crime
and i think that could be a very strong
case
based upon what this investigation shows
as to those agents this is scary it's
devastating and quite frankly the
testimony of these young athletes was
very very moving and clear and very
specific i think they are they're on to
opening a big probe into this case
absolutely terry what do you think the
future of the us gymnastics are after
this hearing how does an olympic
organization stick to landing after
failing these athletes so poorly
it's going to be very difficult brian i
think the usa olympics and the usa
gymnastics both need to take a look at
what their policies are what are their
procedures how are they treating the
women and girls that they are working
with and are they taking their claims
seriously when we heard from simone
biles and michaela moroney and ali
raisman and maggie nichols today they
were very professional and they told
their stories the way they should have
and they asked for some accountability
and i think we're going to have to see
accountability with these two
organizations the same way we have with
the fbi absolutely especially before the
next olympics this cannot continue for
american women
girls boys and men this has to stop now
hopefully that will occur today and
going forward thank you both
tuesday marked the first full day of
witness testimony in the federal case
against former billionaire elizabeth
holmes
former theranos employees and financial
managers testified revealing that at one
point the company was losing two million
dollars a week but we're told the
company would soon generate a billion
dollars per year in its heyday homes
claimed the company would revolutionize
blood testing but later investigations
found many problems with the test on
wednesday witnesses explained it was
common for theriano's proficiency tests
to create mixed results and often failed
tests holmes faces 12 fraud charges for
her connection to the now defunct
theranos
we're now nearing the one-month mark in
the federal trial against r b singer r
kelly after weeks of gripping testimony
from sexual assault accusers prosecutors
are now asking that jurors hear profane
video and audio recordings of the singer
the tapes dating back to 2008 include
audio of kelly screaming at a woman for
lying to him and then beginning to
assault her he can be heard saying quote
if you lie to me i'm going to f you up
in another recording kelly can be heard
threatening a separate woman saying he
will track her down in her home state
and quote something will happen to you
among the underlying charges kelly faces
federal pornography and obstruction
including enticing minors to engage in
criminal sexual activity intimidating
victims and concealing evidence
a missing woman's boyfriend now named a
person of interest in the case as the
search for 22 year old gabby potito
continues in july potato and her
boyfriend brian lowdry left for a
cross-country road trip they detail
their journey taken in potato's van via
social media posts hello hello and good
morning
but since august potato social media has
fallen silent she was believed to be
traveling near grand teton national park
in wyoming when she was last seen days
later laundry returned to his family's
home in florida drying potato's van
without her on tuesday lowj's family
released a statement saying in part
quote it is our hope that the search for
miss potido is successful and that miss
petito is reunited with her family after
that laundry noted his legal counsel
advised him to make no other comments
potido's family fired back in a dueling
statement saying quote how does brian
stay in the background when he is the
one person that knows where gabby is
located on tuesday utah police confirmed
they responded to an incident involving
both laundry and potito two weeks before
she went missing at a time officials
determined no criminal charges would be
filed potito is described as being a
white woman with blonde hair five feet
five inches tall and about 110 pounds
anyone with more information should
contact crime stoppers the number is at
the bottom of your screen
still ahead on law and crime daily the
jury is now deliberating on the fate of
real estate air robert durst we'll bring
you up to speed on the case ahead of the
verdict but first the murder murder
mystery adds murder for hire how south
carolina attorney alex murda got caught
up in a murder for higher plot
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury bonus
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
twisted web of the murder murder mystery
just got even more entangled as a south
carolina lawyer admits he hired a hitman
to kill him all in the name of a 10
million insurance policy
law on crime daily brought you the story
last week after murdoch claimed he was
changing a flat tire when a bullet
grazed his head he survived the shooting
this comes months after murdo's wife and
adult son were found shot to death at
their south carolina home just three
days later murdoch's father died of
cancer all this his lawyer says caused
him to spiral out of control and abuse
opioids after 20 years of addiction
murdoch began paying for the pills
through misappropriated money from his
law firm believing that his 10 million
dollar insurance policy had a suicide
clause murdoch hired 61-year-old curtis
edward smith to kill him at a phony
traffic stop on tuesday murder on his
lawyers came forward with their scheme
it was an attempt on his part to do
something to protect his child he
this is he he didn't want law
enforcement spending more time on this
fake crime okay instead of focusing on
solving uh the murders of of maggie and
paul in an exclusive interview with the
today show murdoch's attorney said the
murder for hire plot had no connection
with his wife and son's double murder
but instead was an act of desperation to
protect his other son none whatsoever
except he was in a dark dark dark place
and wanted to help his son in any way he
could the remaining zombuster in any way
he could and he thought this was the
only way he could leave him with
anything
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney mike corebotix and co-host
terry austin terry i have the utmost
sympathy for those who suffer from
opioid addiction but what could this
murder for hire mean for murder
you know what brian i agree with you i
have sympathy for opioid it's a huge
huge problem here in the united states
obviously but it's a stretch of the
imagination to think that murdoch's
involvement with this murder for hire
plot had anything to do with his drug
use
if his wife and son were actually killed
separate and apart i can understand him
beginning to get depressed using opioids
but then for him to calculate a suicide
plot where he's murdered so he can
collect on the insurance i think is
truly a stretch and he's not taking
responsibility for his own actions even
though he's seemingly doing so i tend to
agree with that terry mike what about
the guy murder hired curtis edwards
would you expect serious charges or even
jail time for him
i would expect serious charges but i
think this is one of those
cases where the process has to play out
it's going to be very interesting as to
what evidence
this person can offer into the case and
we're going to find out was it really a
suicide plot what exactly was it there
just seems to be so many
unusual moving parts in this case i
don't really know brian if it was a good
idea for his council to go on
tv this early to discuss the case when i
think there's a lot of things that need
to be uncovered here that they may not
be aware of right now i think for any
defense attorney in this situation it's
best to sit back listen and see what
develops
i'm hoping for another twist next week
maybe
this guy flips on murdo and we get a
whole new
twist and turn to this web but we'll
have to wait and see how that plays out
just as you said mike thank you both
coming up on law on crime daily a third
degree murder conviction overturned more
on what's next for former minnesota
police officer mohammad noor plus a
father now behind bars after murdering
his five-year-old son with autism how
long of a prison sentence he faces set
to face
[Music]
the day that we have waited four months
for has finally arrived deliberations
are officially underway in california
versus robert durst
robert durst is charged with the murder
of his best friend susan berman who was
found dead in her benedict canyon home
in december 2000. the real estate air
claims that he discovered his best
friend's body got scared and fled the
scene only sending what is now the
infamous cadaver note to help
authorities later discover berman robert
durst is suspected of killing berman
because she allegedly had information
about his missing wife kathy another
murder that durst is accused of and yet
remains uncharged for
testimony lasted approximately four
months with durst spending three weeks
on the stand testifying in his own
defense the jury deliberated for three
hours on tuesday after closing arguments
concluded deliberations resumed on
wednesday at 4 30 eastern time before
the jury started their deliberation john
lewin left them with this
doing it because she was a witness
because he didn't want to accept the
consequences of his conduct
make him accept the consequences go back
there ladies and gentlemen please
do your job do your duty
this is not a difficult case
this is not hard
it's overwhelming
please
go back there
and make this man accept
the consequences for murdering his best
friend susan berlin
turning now to ohio where jurors got
their first glimpse at police
interrogation videos of an accused
arsonist
stanley ford is charged with the murders
of nine of his neighbors by setting
fires in their homes one of the homes
belonged to the huggins and boggs family
were five children and their parents
died in the fire if convicted ford could
face the death penalty before both sides
rested in court on wednesday the
defendant's police interrogation video
was played for the jury and things got
heated between the investigators and
ford
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
switching gears now to tennessee where a
father is sentenced to prison after
being convicted of murdering his son
a jury found joseph ray daniels guilty
of second-degree murder aggravated child
abuse and evidence tampering in
connection with the murders of his
five-year-old nonverbal autistic son
baby joe daniels called
their tennessee 911
two days later he confessed to
investigators that he brutally beat his
son after he urinated on the floor he
went on to say that he dumped his body
in a rural area
though multiple surges have been
conducted the body has yet to be found
three months after his guilty conviction
the judge sentenced daniels to 51 years
in prison afterwards he'll be eligible
for parole baby joe's mother crystal
daniels also faces aggravated child
neglect charges along with a slew of
other charges in connection to the death
of her child the mother appeared briefly
in court on tuesday afternoon where she
pled not guilty to those charges her
motion hearing is set for november 12th
with her trial set to begin in february
of 2022
the trial date is now set for the
ex-pharmaceutical executive martin
shkreli dub farmer bro by the media
shkreli faces a civil suit as state and
federal regulators work to ban him from
the pharmaceutical industry altogether
the charges stem from his decision to
skyrocket the price of derephim a
life-saving drug he held a monopoly over
in the same way shkreli is accused of
illegally boxing out competition to
maintain darafim's high price right now
shkreli is serving a seven year sentence
for securities fraud and is set to be
released in 2022 shkreli's civil trial
is set to begin in december of 2021
after nearly two decades of dead ends
dna evidence helped solve the cold case
death of a florida teenager
since 2002 15 year old faray carter's
family has been left with questions
that's when she was found viciously
stabbed to death in her home on tuesday
officers charged 56-year-old joseph
pillard with first-degree homicide
pilar's motive is still unknown and so
far he has denied all involvement in
carter's death back in 2004 pilar was
sentenced to life in prison on an
unrelated incident stemming from charges
of robbery and a deadly weapon burglary
and attempted kidnapping carter would
have turned 35 years old this month
when we come back a minnesota police
officer is re-sentencing why the third
degree murder charge no longer applies
and what this could mean for convicted
murderer derek shogun
[Music]
welcome back in a startling turn of
events an ex-police officer's third
degree murder conviction is overturned
by the minnesota supreme court experts
say this could pave the way for a
similar appeal by derek chovin
mohamed noor was charged with the 2017
death of justine damon rooscheck who
called
in 911 norm was convicted with
back-to-back charges of third-degree
murder and second-degree manslaughter
since then he's been serving a 12 and a
half year sentence on wednesday the
state supreme court ruled that
prosecutors did not prove nor acted with
a depraved mind without regard for human
life a stipulation that would be needed
for a third degree murder conviction
from here nor will be re-sentenced for
his second-degree manslaughter
conviction
mike how did the court come to reverse
norah's conviction and do you agree
i think in this situation i do brian
because it was very specific and it was
an instantane instantaneous type of
action and he was maybe there was a lot
more question there and a lot more
reassurance that he was acting with
police procedures based upon the facts
as they were given in that decision yeah
it seems like a mental state kind of
argument it's it's maybe more negligent
maybe more reckless but that depraved
mind indifference that's a very
different standard than i think what may
have happened in this situation and i
tend to agree with you as well mike i
think that's a little different than
what he was charged with terry so what
does this mean for muhammad noor and
even derek shovin's murder convictions
well you know nor was charged and
convicted of both the third degree and
second degree if you take away the third
degree murder charge he still faces four
years for the manslaughter charge and so
he could technically get out on release
after two-thirds of that sentence he'll
be eligible but as far as chauvin is
concerned you know don't forget he was
convicted of second-degree murder so he
was committing murder while he was
assaulting someone and he basically has
that higher charge even if the third
degree goes away frankly i don't think
the third degree will go away because i
think it was clear he did act with a
depraved mind so i think that that's
going to stick and don't forget he also
has that manslaughter charge so i think
that that conviction will stand yeah it
kind of makes sense if you if you take
what mike said about the mindset and the
timing muhammad noor the incident or the
the the crime happened just in a few
moments with derek shoving a much longer
period of time so probably won't affect
him as much thank you both and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you